i realized that it wasn't enough for me
to just be
selling clothes you know i wanted to
look at secularity
from uh an african perspective let's see
nigerian perspective you know what is
what is authentic to us it feels like
most of these things are brought to us
from outside the continent it is
important to have
local solutions for me circularity
through an african lens is looking at
where we are what do we need
not what is the rest of the world doing
and how can we
also be a part of it you know you're
absolutely correct you know i mean um
part of what we're supposed to be
talking about i guess is future
narratives
and one of these narratives that you're
talking about is
challenging the night of globalization
you know that's exactly
what my interest in circularity is right
and how do you start using your local
resources
to to change this narrative we need to
be more
conscious of the solutions that we
create for
our reality it is up to us as designers
as makers as creators
to kind of introduce a new language
to say okay this is what's trending now
so there are materials that are
available locally
but it's just that people have an idea
of what modernity looks like or what
contemporary things look like
and if it doesn't correspond to those
things then it's not
seen as valuable so we need to be able
to start having these kinds of
conversations internally with the
materials that we have available to us
you